Lindsey Grahams the South Carolina
senator who joins prime time now so
Chuck's now amnesty Chuck I mean what do
you think about that suspicious timing
Senator well all I can say is your own
is something here my friend Obama had 60
senators in the senate had a majority in
the house and never even brought
immigration up this is an effort by
democrats to try to label us as
anti-hispanic it ain't going to work
here's what should happen uh I hope
Kevin McCarthy's the speaker sooner
rather than later if the house doesn't
send the Senate a border security bill
from Hell we've made a mistake there's
not going to be any deal on immigration
until we secure the Border it's just a
matter of time to a bunch of us get
killed because the border is broken and
terrorism's On The Rise so here's my
message to my Democratic colleagues
there will be no deals on immigration
until we secure the border to my
Republican colleagues in the house send
us a border security Bill strong as hell
and we'll make the Democrats vote on it
in the Senate
why can't Chuck Schumer just say if
we're not having babies in America let's
have some more babies why does he have
to blow up the border and invite the
entire Western Hemisphere into the
country illegally so this is the same
group of people who want to have
taxpayer-funded abortion up to the
moment of birth talking about we don't
have enough people so it makes no sense
it's all politics but let me tell you
about what's going on December the 6th
we're going to have an election in
Georgia I can't wait to Herschel Walker
to come to the Senate he will cancel out
a lot of this crazy stuff how about this
idea we're going to discharge over 5 000
soldiers from our military because they
won't take the coveted vaccine we've had
four million people come to this country
legally unvaccinated they get a free
weekend in Las Vegas Herschel Walker
needs to come to the Senate
lindseygram.com every penny you give me
not half of it all of it goes to
Herschel in the Georgia GOP look at the
policy opportunity we have we should
have a vote on the floor of the Senate
that would make sure that people do not
get discharged who are willing to fight
for this country because they refuse the
vaccine we got a dumb country we're
living we're letting illegal immigrants
come here unvaccinated going to free
trips All Over America and you want to
discharge a warrior we should have a
border security bill from Hell coming
out of the the house and we should do
energy dominance and we need the seat
folks listen we won the house today
December the 6th let Herschel win
lindseygram.com the money goes to the
Georgia GOP it goes to Herschel one less
vote for this crazy crap if we can win
in December we'll have the window our
back
I can see that bumper sticker right now
one less vote for the crazy team
herschel.com
yeah thank you Senator Graham I really
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else